bella tutti ragazzi e poi vedete questo
momento sono fa dj non ci sia un nuovo
video sugli stipiti 3.0 la cosa mi
riempie di gioia ragazzi perché il primo
videogame che faccio con joystick da
quando ciò la mano che funziona il
playset che facciamo oggi ragazze dei
set di the forsaken che questo qui
passando appunto su uno star wars the
forsaken sky un film che è uscito
l'altro giorno siccome non ancora fermi
che non ci arrivo come non c'è yoda che
io sappia in questo devo accontentarmi
di o rei o film non importa tra l'altro
siccome non posso 6 ott
ecco la cosa triste che non posso dare
io da ragazzo l'unica roba che volevo e
yoda però non c'è purtroppo meno
chewbecca tanto tempo fa in una galassia
lontana lontana
lo sapevo a chi è appreso fosse un
insulto ti è per te adesso pianeta per
premi gli otto perfetto quanto
scommettiamo ragazzi che non si abbassa
la visuale c'è un astronave quanto ci
scommettiamo attenzione ecco lo sapevo
ma perché io sono un veggente ragazzi io
le sole cose una fuga audace scappa
dallo staff di sì ma io chi sono
fermi giochi sono solo lei può dire come
liz vengo si sistemi sempre aiuto fisco
nano sono stato io a distruggere tutte
le avete parcheggiato male caprai fai
vai vai vai vai amodio dove siamo in
bank dove sia o no sto spendendo di
scappare non fate caso a me non fa
peccato solamente all'inizio ne sì io
abbiamo sfondato tutto non ci credo
l'abbia fatta giorgia con ragazzi jaku
che non è una scuola
è un pianeta bello ei
ottima la nave si è schiantata ho perso
il pilota lei
oddio vivi 89 congratulazioni ora
possiedi questo personaggio ci siamo
posso andare allora devo scappare da
jaku il problema non è come a ecco come
fatto lo più ragazzi non mi ricordo i
tasti e triste e molto triste siamo
ragazzi toglietevi non faccio
l'idraulico note che mi spunta di dubbi
e di fatti capire come una ragazza con
delle braccine così riesca a sollevare
una scatola che più grossa di lei
hai un futuro nel calcio zaia ne pensate
giocare la juventus come lo ha detto va
bene i ragazzi ci siamo il problema è
che se uno è un boss moscato ad alcuno
su famiglia ho parlato è papà massa ad
avere questo non è proprio una smart è
un po più grossa la macchina e non c'è
la patente è che ci siamo riusciti ma
non c'è verso
rimarremo intrappolati qui a vita ciò
che ha fatto sia lodato il cielo ragazzi
ce l'abbiamo fatta
cosa fare se esercitando per fare yoga
fate capire aiuto come chiudeva ciao lo
farò fuori con questa pistola finta c'è
una mira ragazzini incredibile ciò detto
distrutto al giorno puntato d'oro fermi
ho trovato non sa fare niente trovato il
traghetto d'oro con lo prendo lascia
privo dai ragazzi si così se li prende
si no ma come zio è bravo ce l'avevamo
preso ma ci devo finire un spararmi io
devo toccare le basta ad ora perché ne
so io dico uno di cento è il miracolo
sono trovato uno zio
cosa ho trovato un mercato un segretario
ha detto grazie sono o di un altro drago
ma davanti solo una volta nella vita
ragazzi li troverò tutti a 100 prima o
poi non ci credo mai veramente una beffa
non è incastrato sarà appena partito dai
si va beh ragazzi poi basta mi scusi lei
non l'ho visto a sapere tipo
ma cos'è staff a cos'è un tris ma palma
scusa scusa azienda giuro non volevo un
giorno
favorire abituato vero frate scusami e
non volevo ragazzi andiamo avanti perché
se non a me spero tu abbia qualcosa di
buono per divertire sì ho trovato questo
ragazzo controvento torna quando farai
sul serio ritorno a quando avrai
recuperato abbastanza materiale ma non
possono semplicemente rubare la
navicella facciamo primati ma ci sono
emissioni da fare ma dai non ci credo ma
io posso sparare alla gente a casa
questo mi attacca cosa ti ho fatto non è
che guardate cosa vuoi miei miei belli
miei fan
ciao salutami ci becca se lo vedi questo
che corre lo si sta facendo
oddio che è prodotto afferma ma come
possa afferrare le persone non mi piaci
come persona quindi devo finché era un
calcio abbi pazienza stop
ecco io ho preso a calci la gente a caso
edizione buca 1 e dei galli mentre di
via ragazzi fantastico abbiamo trovato
questa vecchia console questa è una
console
se riusciamo ad aggiustarlo scommetto
che potremo giocare un sacco di gioco
attiva la console con assetti non è che
sono tecnico viola terminale ha mai
preso per né anonymous
pensavo che fare gli hacker fosse così
facile ma posso anche giocare sul serio
ma come gioco nel gioco sei serio da non
averne preso un proiettile di pieno come
si spara purtroppo non posso
anzi posso sparare titolo che solo
sono diventato sono uscito tutti ragazzi
è diventato un killer ma che roba che
pensavo di dover sopravvivere non titoli
a fare i punteggi che sapevo mancano
ancora un sacco di punti però ce la
possiamo fare lo sento mio lucapist non
si lucapist che sia l'unica cosa
potevano su di morale sono i suoi
dolcetti preferiti a quello è un
dolcetto zio
io non l'ho mangieri neanche sotto
tortura prova ben 3 milioni tranquilli
comunque cambia outfit e ti prego lo
stop berretto non si può guardare che
potrebbe fare tranquillamente lui cielo
che deve mandare nei giro perché non
c'ha voglia di la verità non c'è voglia
e haga fuori dove state correndo e nava
e la maratona di correre sul posto è
sedili fenomeno anche una lacca vecchio
tali ragazzi continuate così fate sport
ragazzi ci andrei aver fatto 2000
precisi ma fermi che devo salire sul mio
bolide vogliatemi tutti che devo andare
a comprare le nuove ciabatte infradito
perfetto ci sia un duro lavoro
ricompensati guida è quindi il primo di
spendono tutti
perché i soci cassato la moto ciò fatta
sapevo di farcela e l'ho fatto io ci
mancherebbe a posto anzi io posso sbatti
in faccia adesso
o mi dai la nave c'è un filmato tu mi
dai il trade e livio allora ti presto le
mie navi
te l'ho detto anche il droide lo ceiling
forse non hai capito
non te lo stop di eventi
dobbiamo svegliarci ragazzi mi sa che ci
dobbiamo picchiare cioè alla fine dopo
tutto sto casino ha fatto anche storie
ci manca solo questo era lo presero
preso storie dei perché muore a posto
l'abbiamo fatta adesso c'è il millennium
falcon ci mancava solo questo posso
comandarlo io non tocco damiani
valeva la possiamo fare bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye
adesso mi un seminario dobbiamo seminare
ragazzi ce la posso fare che la rete in
me credi in me film è vero che credi
mesi che crede in me lo vedete la faccia
come convinto che questa è questa la
scena che volevo volevo giocare
assolutamente tutta la vita triangolo
per sparare perfetto
ragazzi io sono un pericoloso alla guida
di certi veivoli me lo dico perché la
tectonic con il millennium falcon
proprio come se stesse guidando una
triciclo bravo bravo bravo bravo laura
sterminati tutti ma can 5 l'abbiamo
fatta
adesso di dietro c'è non bastava la
anche io dovunque passa ragazzi ci sono
esplosioni
esplode il tutto un pianeta intero un
altro troppo importante importante
esserci riusciti poi prova a calciare
oggetti invece che lanciarlo ho provato
a calciare una persona prima non ti
preoccupare che ci ho provato
c'è qualcosa ci agganciati quando
forzato la baia d'attracco
stiamo per essere bordati i ragazzi
signore e signori sta per entrare uno
dei miei attori preferiti su vecchia è
un fenomeno vi prego perché non posso
comandare su becca il mio figo comunque
ragazzi che un culo l'episodio è stato è
stato veramente figo poi valeri e miche
dimmi chi è posto non posso non ancora
probabilmente alla fine ma d'estate
lanciato da ragazzo olis spero che mi
sia piaciuto è un credo che l'episodio
su disney finiti e sul play set di the
forsaken spero che il vostro amore per
su beckham c'è il mio amore per se becca
sia anche vostro nel senso che non sia
il ricorso stupido a vedere il suo becca
come un sex symbol
se la pensate ormai ragazzi un bel mi
piace come se tutto video che lascia
momento mi piace stare se rischiate
riuscirvi diavolo posso invito è la
piazza